this week 48 Hours investigates a more
than two decade-old murder case
involving a Missouri mother the
investigation was reopened after new
questions emerged about the conviction
of a teenager accused of killing his
mother Michael polite spent 23 years
behind bars before he was released on
parole earlier this year 48 Hours
correspondent Aaron Moriarty reports
sisters Crystal and Melanie polid have
vivid memories of December 5th 1998. the
day Crystal received a phone call that
they had to go to their mother's house
right away
she was dead I just sat on my bed and I
just kept saying I don't want to go I
don't want to go 40 year old Rita police
had been murdered her son Michael was
only 14 years old at the time he says he
woke up that morning and found her on
fire I was scared to death I didn't know
what to do Michael told investigators
that he had no idea what happened to his
mom but when he failed a voice stress
test and an accelerant sniffing dog
alerted to his shoes he was suddenly a
suspect they were telling me that I did
something two days after the crime
Michael polite was arrested for his
mother's murder were there any injuries
on Michael none any blood found on him
on his clothing no no weapon no when
Michael went on trial in 2002 he was
convicted and sentenced to life
Michael would spend years in prison
before a new team of lawyers would begin
re-examining his case Megan crane is one
of his attorneys the state essentially
never really had any case against this
kid Michael's team says the evidence
used to convict him was problematic and
specifically that the accelerant
sniffing dog alerted to a chemical used
in the shoe manufacturing process
48 Hours has learned that the
investigation into Rita's murder has
been reopened and Michael claims he
thinks he knows who is really
responsible there's only one individual
that I know that hates her that much to
do that to her
and Aaron Moriarty joins us now good
morning good morning this is another
example of where investigators just
jumped too fast on the first suspect and
I see that over and over again in this
well one thing I'm wondering from your
report if Michael was released from
parole why are his attorneys now
fighting to get him another hearing form
get him back in court well because he
was released on Pro but that means he's
a convicted felon a convicted killer
um he wants to clear his name and he
says he wants to get Justice for his
mother because I mean a lot of people
wonder did he do it or did he not even
though he's out why did police zero in
on him so quickly well I mean they
should have at least looked at him I
mean he was in the house when his mom
died and they thought he acted a little
inappropriately when they were taken him
to the Sheriff's Office he asked who's
going to get my mother's truck but his
sister said that's all his mother had so
it was a normal thing and they ignored
the fact or didn't take seriously enough
the fact that there wasn't real physical
evidence I mentioned no weapon there was
no time to get rid of a weapon she
fought her attacker he had no injuries
no blood on him but he he also was a
troubled child so they focused on him
and it was kind of over after that well
real treat to get to see you two days in
a row but a very interesting case uh
folks can see the case against Michael
polite on 48 hours tomorrow night at 10
Central oh sorry 10 9 Central right here
on CBS and Paramount Plus